[Music]
it seems so frequently on alternative
views we are so fortunate and having
people present to you information that
they have experienced at the spot of
contention so to speak we've had people
come to us who have lived in Central
America or taken trips to Cuba or to
various places in Africa or people from
Russia etc well tonight we are very
fortunate to have Charlie Clements with
us charlie is a person and Austinite who
started out as a an Air Force officer
flying missions in Vietnam now he's
coming to us as a doctor who has been
functioning in the rebel-held areas of
El Salvador that's quite a change quite
a gap from Vietnam to El Salvador in
those capacities but we're going to find
out what's happening down there and
we're going to find up the Charlie
Clements story tonight he has testified
before Congress on a couple of occasions
he's he's made presentations at
universities around the country and has
also been on many of the national media
TV shows etc so we have an awful lot in
store for you tonight
Charlie can you start off by telling us
your background how was it you left
Austin and went to the Air Force Academy
and wound up in Vietnam well I grew up
in Austin and my father was in the Air
Force my older brother went to the Air
Force Academy and as I look back on it I
was raised from the time I was this high
to to be an Air Force officer it was
certainly a voluntary decision and a
very honorable thing to do and in that
time I remember it same Edwards when it
was announced that I had won the
appointment that not only was I very
happy but most of my classmates in the
school were happy for me as well
could you tell us a bit about your
experiences in Vietnam what did you
actually do in your military experience
and what disillusioned you with American
foreign policy the American military and
led you to embark on your new life I was
fortunate enough to have gone
to UCLA to graduate school for a few
months after the Academy and I think in
some ways there were some seeds planted
there and what your was it that was 1967
60 and a little bit of 68 and I recall
vividly passing by those long lines of
people in silent vigils thinking that
they're a little bit confused I'm going
to Vietnam soon to defend the right to
protest but that's what America is all
about
and I never really had any dialogue with
people there but when I got to Vietnam I
slowly began to see things that bothered
me now this was at a time before
Watergate so for me to come to terms
with the fact that the president was
knowingly lying to the American public
was very difficult and I remember one
time Nixon coming on TV and telling the
American public there were no troops and
Louis nor did he intend to commit any I
knew that day that my classmates were
flying out of unmarked airplanes and
secret air bases resupply by America
c-130s so I began to come to grips with
those contradictions I looked around me
one time and my job was flying personnel
around a cargo of medical evacuation I
was a c-130 pilot and found in the back
of the aircraft that the majority people
were black Chicano or poor whites that
that the kinds of people that had been
around the UCLA for instance weren't
there and I recalled how everyone was
was busily trying to get a deferment was
trying to get into graduate school or to
get married or have a child or whatever
it took there was this whole series of
things that had been very foreign to me
and I saw the effect of that because the
kids I was I was taking out to those
fire bases were for the most part there
because they had no alternatives they
had no choices that other people had
what was the bang for their attitudes
were they looking forward to they want
to go kill him some gooks or were they
resentful or were they did they have any
awareness once they were scared they
were scared to talk to me because I was
an officer and even engaging in the
conversation was difficult and it was
obvious to me that these were people who
who wouldn't challenge Authority very
easy for white middle-class people to
challenge authority
when their fathers maybe hired a lawyer
for them or tried to get them a
psychiatrist to help them get out of
things but these were kids from from
rural Kansas for instance who who never
would have challenged the authority of a
draft board and what were your actual
activities yourself in Vietnam were you
doing on flying missions were you in
combat I was flying water term combat
missions but that means just flying in
any area that was contested at some
point I had decided I didn't want to
kill anybody so I was a noncombatant I
flew a c-130 my missions really covered
most of the theater I flew into Cambodia
I flew in the Thailand into Vietnam and
many other parts of Southeast Asia and
it afforded me much more than the
bird's-eye view of the war that most
soldiers had who were just trying to
preserve their physical integrity I
didn't have a very dangerous job and in
the sense that others did did you see a
lot of ecological damage and a lot of
defoliation and destruction environment
from the bombing oh absolutely I
remember looking at at areas of Laos and
areas of Vietnam but I recall more
vividly Laos flying over the the Ho Chi
Minh Trail that looked like the moon I
mean just knew acres of pockmarked
fields that were without vegetation and
there was much of the countryside that
was just completely destroyed by the
bombing and the deployment war you
mentioned Cambodia that was supposed to
be a neutral country was it not that
wasn't even supposed to be involved yet
America was fine secret missions in
there that was one of the things that
would lead to my decision to not
continue flying anymore I flew the State
Department in there on secret missions
and during that time I found out about
the secret bombing warf which had been
going on for more than a year I was led
to believe by intelligence operatives
who were friends and in Saigon that
after the government of sanik fell that
we had in fact engineered the coup that
led to lon all coming to power because
we wanted to bomb and invade the
sanctuary and CNO had said no that's
going to engulf us in this war and I
found myself flying troops to the border
that is a Cambodian Vietnamese
in late April of 1970 preparing for
invasion of Cambodia and that was the
time when I decided I didn't want to
have anything more to do with it and
what the hell deerforce react to this
well they didn't know quite how to react
because I had no contact with an
anti-war movement it wasn't a political
statement it was a statement of what I
perceived as right and wrong and I even
still felt obliged to stay in the Air
Force so I said I would like a change of
duty not related to Southeast Asia and
explained that I was becoming more and
more angry about everything I saw there
and felt that it would be better if I
had a change of assignment so I was sent
as a pilot was who who had any problems
was sent to a psychiatrist
that psychiatrist said he had to send me
back to the United States where someone
could evaluate me when I started talking
about a secret bombing war a secret
invasion a Phoenix program in which
thousands of suspected peasant
sympathizers were being assassinated I
think he thought I was crazier than a
lute and he committed me to a
psychiatric ward there in the ward I
went through a lot of confusion I went
through some depression some anger I
wasn't quite sure what I was doing there
and eventually got a good lawyer who
helped me to kind of make some decisions
and that was that I could have fought
this in the courts and he basically said
I had no chance at all that they would
throw the book at me I wasn't a
conscientious objector I refused to say
in fact I wouldn't have fought in a
non-combat capacity in World War two so
the choice was to accept a psychiatric
discharge which I which I did and what
year was this that was in 1971 when I
was finally discharged it not ironic
that sounds so much like what happens in
the Soviet Union they find people who
they don't like or people who descent
they say you're crazy and they send you
to a psychiatric hospital which is the
same as jail well to some extent I don't
do it as an abuse of psychiatry like the
Soviet Union but I was an officer had I
been enlisted man I probably would have
been in jail you just instead of in a
psychiatric ward and I was on a national
radio program the other day and someone
called up from a cracy media and said
now we want those listeners to know that
this man is crazy that he has
miss charge psychiatrist then called up
and said I discharged lots of pilots
because any of them that that protested
what was going on met with a similar
kind of disposition so when there were a
lot of so I suppose there were others I
didn't meet but a few but time to me it
seems like a criterion of rationality to
get out of the war because what they're
doing there is wrong because they're
killing because there's all these
problems with the whole Vietnam foreign
policy but it seems to me a rational
person would see in - well it was a
cacciatore because what they said to me
was that I had to be willing to fly
anyplace in the world at any time for
the Air Force if I was to be fit to fly
I said I would fly anyplace in the world
for the airforce any time except in
Vietnam so that made me not fit to fly
by their criteria and so there was kind
of a catch-22 involved in the in the
whole time so when you got discharged
what happened that well I found myself
and it was 25 without having any idea of
what I wanted in life I had always done
what was expected and what was right I
had been the good high school student I
had been the good cadet I was an
outstanding graduate I had been the good
graduate student the good pile at the
good officer and now what was I to be
the good and it forced me to re-evaluate
my whole value system I would travel in
a third world along and work in the
third world and come to understand
politically what was happening in
Southeast Asia and also what our role in
the world was to a greater extent and
would come to accept us to some extent
the fact that my psychiatric discharge
wasn't going to affect me in the least
and doing all I wanted to do but were
the third-world countries you were in
and what experience led to these
insights well I worked in as a ordinary
seaman on some banana boats I guess you
might you might
home and so I visited Central America
and that was the first time I came in
contact with some of the conditions
there I would drive a tractor and work
as a as a field hand and some islands in
the Pacific would work as a health
worker and in India and living close to
people in the third world I came to
understand a little bit more how they
perceive the United States but also how
our policies affected their lives to
some extent when particularly when
you're in Central America did you see
the indigenous poverty or suffering or
oppression that the people are
experiencing that would lead them to
seek revolutionary change do you have
some experiences of that order did that
come later I saw that but the close
understanding of that that would lead to
the revolution came came later because
certainly the suffering there was not
much different than the suffering in
India and yet in India it has in fact
it's probably worse there it hasn't yet
led to the kind of change that we're
seeing in Latin America so then you went
to medical school and became a public
health I got a master's degree in public
health as well as a car that's correct
and then after graduating where did you
hang your shingle well I went to Salinas
California where I began working with a
large indigenous population of farm
workers and it was there I first began
to see refugees from El Salvador what
year was this that was in 1980 and 1981
and what then led you to actually go
down and practice medicine in El
Salvador I began hearing echoes of what
I heard 20 years before as a young man
there were calls for more helicopters
calls for more advisors there were cries
if we don't stop the middle Salvador
will have to stop them as they come
across the Rio Grande I had heard that
before only it had been if we don't stop
them in Vietnam we'll have to stop them
at the Golden Gate Bridge and the people
I saw still more physical and
psychological marks of torture I think
that that we all live in a lot of
abstractions in this country and seeing
these people transform for me some of
those abstractions about repression into
the human tragedy I have been speaking
about also know for some time probably
almost a year by that time a delegation
of American physicians had gone there
and documented a campaign of terror
against the health sector they had
written a brochure called abuses of
medical neutrality in which they
outlined and documented physicians being
shot in the operating room nurses killed
in clinic's patients dragged from the
hospital beds and shot the closure of
the only medical school much of the
faculty that wasn't arrested were were
driven into exile and I was speaking to
medical colleagues here about what was
happening in the health sector of
Salvador becoming more frustrated
people's inability to grasp the
seriousness of what was happening and
also fearing another Vietnam I began to
look at a way that I might make a larger
contribution than I was making just
speaking about it and in the years
intervening between Vietnam I had made a
personal commitment to non-violence
so I began examining what role I might
play in this process to prevent a
Vietnam but also to perhaps be a witness
to what was going on because there was
so much distortion the people I was
seeing weren't communists weren't
terrorists weren't subversives there
were people who were trying to change
their lives I I remember very vividly
meeting a 54 year old schoolteacher who
had organized her 12 teacher Elementary
School and received a death threat then
beaten and fled the country the next day
knowing they meant business because they
had killed her brother a principal of a
high school just a week before
and that was the kind of patient that I
was meeting that was fleeing from the
repression in El Salvador fleeing the
government not the revolutionary
Democratic Front and how expensive is
the repression in El Salvador well some
more examples of the sort of thing that
the people were suffering that led you
to actively intervene the revolutionary
Democratic Front was made up of just
about every sector of society there it
included the Federation Christian
campesinos which had come under severe
attack it included on does the National
Association of teachers which came under
severe attack
it included mythbust and an independent
movement of professionals and
technicians that had come under attack
as as engineers lawyers and physicians
it included the social and Christian
Democrats who had tried to bring about
reforms in the first hunter and had to
drop out because they couldn't control
the violence so that touched virtually
every sector of the society labor
organization all finestra's the umbrella
organization of unions was most
viciously attacked as well basically
anyone who is trying to bring about
change was label a communist and we I
think we know well the stories of the
religious workers first a number of
priests the nuns and Archbishop Romero
of course we were also labeled
communists or subversive because they
were trying to adjust issues of social
change so as a reign of terror that has
been going on in El Salvador anyone who
opposes the government is immediately
labeled a communist or subversive and is
subject to severe attack repression
torture and murder even oh absolutely
and it can continue partially because no
one is ever brought to trial for that so
we heard in the los los ojos massacre
which occurred in January of this year
there were 18 Indians working their land
in eastern El Salvador one of the large
landowners wanted to bring a road
through that land that was their
cooperative and they objected to that he
pointed out to the local militias that
these men were in fact subversives
soldiers came and massacred about 18 of
them that was the first case that the
new human rights organization about
falador has has investigated and now the
men who conducted the investigation
fears for his life the major who
directed the soldiers in that massacre
received a promotion and no one has been
brought to trial part there have been
40,000 deaths in the last 40 months none
of which have ever been brought to trial
regardless of whether it's the nones
40,000 40,000 40 months or what most of
the estimates are and yet there's been
at least four different certifications
by the Reagan administration that the
human rights situation is improving in
El Salvador there is not as much torture
and murder etc what is your response
when you see that are these people just
uninformed are they cynical the Congress
or whoever that just rubber stamps or
accepts well they don't rubber stamp but
they have no actual say in it the
president certifies and the Congress
doesn't approve or disapprove without
certification I just participated in the
post certification hearings and many of
the Congress persons are very very
skeptical and certainly point out that
there appears to be no progress that the
military isn't controlled that land
reform isn't working but that doesn't
keep the president from certifying now
but I don't think that's an unusual
circumstance we heard that the president
today at the American Bar Association
meeting was telling people that he has a
much better record and women's issues
and minority issues and the public would
believe in that he's been misrepresented
and I think if he says the Emperor is
naked he expects people to believe it
soon
Charlie you brought a documentary with
us to look at can you introduce it tell
us a bit about it well it was made soon
after I had entered El Salvador and my
participation it was somewhat of an
accident
there was an American film crew who
would come there to film a little bit
about what life was like in the control
zones that is there is that the
opposition controls in El Salvador
they agreed to film this to use for
raising money for humanitarian aid the
film was not made without some costs two
of the people were killed who were
trying to carry some of the film out of
El Salvador of course the the
photographers risked their lives even
making this film but it gives you a
little bit of the reality about El
Salvador and I had just been there for a
short time when it was made but there's
there's nothing inaccurate about what I
said at the time I was still somewhat
untested but that would that would
change very very quickly I think I
mentioned in the film that the hospital
I was in was subject to being overrun
and we kept it minimally equipped so we
could put everything on her back and run
it was overrun and burned about two
weeks later and those are the kind of
conditions that we dealt with most of
the year there let's take a look at it
this is an American doctor in Torino
Salvador to work in the areas controlled
by the photobooth lumati National
Liberation Front guerillas he is
bringing with him 75 pounds of medicine
and equipment for 10,000 people yes
yesterday they fooled us
this young woman is not untypical of
what I've seen here
she has an abscess in her leg the small
entry you can see there's were a grenade
fragment entered when she was about nine
months pregnant I've seen a lot of
chronic infections hearing a lot of
abscesses from people who receive small
wounds but are unable to have intended
for some time after after they received
them she's yet to receive any
antibiotics simply because there aren't
any we're trying to open up the entry
wound and drain this hot compresses a
few times a day and hopefully won't have
to go deeper to explore the abscess she
received this morning when she was 9
months pregnant she walked three days
and then she delivered her baby after
that and didn't have any treatment until
that until that fourth day so this is
the types of problems we're seeing here
and most of the patients I'm seeing are
civilians who weren't combatants and
we're just innocent victims well as a
physician I think that what I can
accomplish may be very little since the
only medicine and only equipment I may
have is what I can carry on my back but
I think my presence here is symbolic and
is very important of the Solidarity of
many people in the United States that at
far in sympathy with the struggle of the
people here in El Salvador I've been
told again and again when I tell the
people that I bring the solidarity of
many people that they know that the
people of the United States aren't their
enemy it's the government of the United
States that's creating their problems
here I was working in a County Hospital
in California doing some solidarity work
as well and I was struck by the
resonance that that I found between the
struggle of the campesinos here and the
farmworkers in California and how well
they understood the importance of
solidarity
most of my solitary work though was with
medical communities because those are
the ones that that I understand the best
and one very important report that I
would talk about was the report of the
Public Health Commission Morrison
a distinguished American physicians came
down to El Salvador and interviewed many
people in the health sector from the
Ministry of Health on down what they
found was quite shocking and they they
related and documented a number of
physicians being shot in the operating
room patients being dragged from their
beds and being shot patients and
physicians being killed in clinics in
front of other patients in a fairly
brutal fashion
which in general amounted to a system of
terror to keep the medical profession
here and the health profession in
general from treating anyone that had
any rooms and as we know about 90% of
the casualties of this war civilians and
their plight began to worry me as I
continued to give solidarity talks when
I left Vietnam I had a firm commitment
to non-violence and I think over the
years I've kind of considered myself a
Quaker more than any other religion so I
had to examine very very closely before
I came down here the the apparent
conflict between non-violence and what I
was participating in as a revolutionary
struggle I think one has to consider
though the the violence that the
government has done to people here
through starvation and through
unemployment and through years of
oppression that hasn't allowed them to
receive health care or education or to
organize in unions I think that kind of
violence is probably far worse than the
kind of violence the people will have to
resort to to attain social justice here
the brahmapuri won't carry many hands
yeah this is coming down T Ramon a
former medical student he and the doctor
are discussing the best way of dividing
up the sparse amount of medicine
available in this camp he was half
Italian
I see for lasagna mucho mas York si I
wish you had a sensor for smelling your
cameras right now you could you could
smell the mold enos of this this
medicine that we're trying to enter out
this is a precious supply that these
people had to bury when they left las
cabañas in November as a result of a
government offensive they just had to
quickly bury it and yesterday they sent
a commando team back to to dig it up
they were able to recover the medicine
but as you can see it's most of the
packages or moldy and a lot of the
medicine was was destroyed unfortunate
there's no antibiotics here Burris um
cause there's a some lidocaine much of
the aluminum caps were were eroded there
are some catheters and some of the
equipment so it'll be certainly useful
as they're expecting a government
offensive any any day against this this
village itself
Capelli doing pasión this is doctor
husband she's in charge of the clinics
at the girl in front of us Appa she was
treating a man whose leg was fractured
by shrapnel from a 250 pound bomb doctor
has me explains that the paramedics
initially applied a bamboo splint the
man's broken leg when he arrived at the
clinic a plaster cast was applied little
food atom in the middle
looks like it's pretty bad the doctor is
supervising an inexperienced paramedic
pulling an infected tooth the tools
being used are part of the medical
equipment purchased by the doctor
[Music]
I'm open
this is the Seletar hospital were about
four hours by foot from San Salvador
right now when the offensive starts this
will be the closest hospital and the
referral hospital for the second Moscow
region I was out I'm the only position
in this hostel we have three experienced
nurses and several unexperienced
paramedics here as you can see our
equipment is fairly permanent this is
our entire stock of medicine for my lab
we received our first two patients this
morning a head wound and through Haman
who tried to think you've seen already
naturally we have to do things
differently here than they would
someplace else if I was in the United
States we would have opened that hand
and tended the third attendant as it was
that young man will probably not hope to
regain the use of his hand because we
won't be able to attend and repair
and we have no plaster for mobilization
so we'll have this part his hand and
hope that he can get enough of my phone
about the amount of coffee conditions
here are pretty rough the table I'm
seeing on is an old kitchen table this
will be our operating table and were
prepared to do abdominal and thoracic
surgery if necessary and so this is
Infosys hospital I watch the spectacle
have to do something we have some
anesthesia here we're hoping to get a
lantern so we can have a little more
light for operations and we're expecting
a lot of action in the next and next few
days is the offensive picks up pace
I don't know I'll open this is a leader
I will miss outside that will stop the
volcano and it's inherited by the
offensive against unsolvable start for
about four hours by foot from san
salvador this is the frontline hospital
and they've had a week of feverish
activity preparing sterilizing Vantage's
training paramedics and and getting our
surgical equipment ready as you saw we
had a real sparse supply of medicines
and has mean the physician in charge of
this whole sector and his focus but kept
this hospital Melanie equipped because
there's a chance that we'll get overrun
we have to be able to put everything on
her backs and run if that's the case the
commander of this column asked me to
examine his troops to basically do a
screen check for combat and most of them
mostly young men of course certainly
physical fit or they wouldn't they
wouldn't be here and I'm basically
checking for a database as well so we
can all if they have any tetanus
vaccination to see if they know their
blood type check past wounds that they
might have gotten and
any kind of minimum data that might be
helpful to us later on I find about 3/4
of them have had malaria so the fact
that there's a clinical anemia and the
fact that that there are more members
and I was suspected in young men of this
age group isn't real surprising probably
1/4 of them had previous old wounds of
note I think the physicians is the fact
that there's not an abdominal or thorax
wound here which i think basically means
that people don't survive those kind of
wounds you hear most of them superficial
wounds that's basically the kind of
things that insane
[Music]
the complete
[Music]
welcome
working frankly to help this man who is
shot in both legs by a government sniper
these paramedics had neither the
experience nor the medical aid to save
their companion he was turned over to
the Green Cross in the hopes that they
would give him the proper treatment but
later Green Cross volunteers watched in
horror as National Guardsmen executed
the wounded guerrilla before we left key
burrito we got a box of medicines from
the people doing solidarity work in
Europe and I just wanted to comment that
every aspirin every band-aid every piece
of gauze every piece of soap and that
box of supplies was so appreciated will
be put to a maximum use and says if
every pill here is precious I count how
many more urinary tract infections I can
treat I count how many more courses of
antibiotics I can give and I just wanted
to assure you those doing solidarity
work that all of your efforts are
greatly appreciated and magnified more
than you can you can ever understand
from from where you are si puede God
idea for more information on how you can
help right too Kousaka COS CA p o-- box
1194 Salinas California nine three nine
OH - how did you enter El Salvador and
work behind the line so to speak work in
rebel-held territory you must have had
to have some type of clearance or
negotiations with the rebels in order to
do this well that's correct I went to
Mexico City where I met with
representatives of the Revolutionary
Democratic Front the political arm of
the Opposition and negotiated the terms
of my service which were that I would
remain neutral in accordance with the
Geneva Conventions that I would not
carry arms and that I would be with a
civilian population I also said I hope
to communicate with the American public
they couldn't guarantee that but they
said it would be a local
option that was dependent on security
conditions and so you entered then El
Salvador in March of 1982 I went to the
cassava front an area about 20 miles
north of San Salvador and in that area
which is 15 miles by 15 miles or eight
hours on a side walking there were about
10,000 civilians 40% of whom were under
age 12 that were to be my responsibility
for the next year gracious what did what
is life like there what type of
conditions are the people facing and
also what are the types of changes which
the rebels have made in the areas where
in which they have under their control
well those are broad questions but okay
we take for what are the Swift strokes
and them working there is very positive
in some ways because I think the society
that's unfolding is a reflection of
their of their hopes for the future
there are for instance many agricultural
cooperatives functioning there now
called revolutionary cooperatives 10
years ago those might have been called
compazine owned cooperatives of the
Federation of Christian campesinos or
they might have been called Catholic
cooperatives so despite the fact that
malnutrition is the most serious problem
in El Salvador there are very few cases
of franc malnutrition in Leguizamo Front
food is distributed more equitably the
fishing cooperative that catches 150
pounds of fish a day distributes that
equitably so the pregnant women and the
wounded patients have higher protein
needs get that fish for instance there
is a functioning civil government
although primitive every town has a
talent council made up of
representatives of the health sector of
the education sector of the agricultural
or production sector of the local
militias of the auto injustice
committees which are the primitive but
functioning legal system and of the
the mayors of the villages those popular
committees as they're called make
decisions on behalf of the villages and
meet with what the people wants every
two weeks in open forums where
priorities are discussed them and
problems are solved sounds like New
England town meetings of another century
in American Life a sort of a form of
participatory democracy well they're
very they're very similar to that people
ask me sometimes they say well our
officials elected because somehow we
equate elections with democracy and I
couldn't say they're always elected
they're selected a health care worker
would be giving more medicine to his
family than distributing to the village
and they would call him before the
village and discuss it if his attitude
wasn't right they would ask him to step
down and they would say who else wants
to serve us and maybe two people raised
their hands there say now why do you
want to serve us and then discuss it and
then say well let's give this person a
try and so there was a there was a
process of perhaps agreement by
consensus on how decisions were reached
by a very seldom saw solve votes as such
what about votes here whoever has the
most money can get the election
basically by maybe 85% of the time what
are they doing for education well there
are thirty elementary schools there and
there's also a dolt education available
for people that want to read and write
and a lot of the adults are learning to
read and write but there are a number of
tough conditions there one there's no
electricity and everything in a control
zone has to be smuggled in so there very
few batteries and candles were precious
so what takes place takes place during
the day and those hours are very
precious for performing or doing
whatever work is necessary so the adults
that want to learn do so a great
sacrifice because they have to sacrifice
time from their primary jobs whatever
those are what about the situation of
women we know in Latin America women
suffered double burdens of oppression in
most countries and I had heard from a
woman from El Salvador that in the so
called liberated zones the situation of
women had improved greatly did you see
any evidence of this yourself well they
participating in the revolution and
women in general are bringing those
issues into people's consciousness there
are going to be changes but very slow
ones there is a machismo built into that
society that is not overturned in in a
matter of a few years women now almost
assume a double burden because they are
always mothers and heads of households
first and many of us say I want to work
in a revolutionary agricultural
cooperative so that means they'll put in
three hours in that that doesn't lessen
their housework
Calvin army the men now are washing the
corn to make tortillas they're grinding
the corn to make the tortillas they're
washing their own clothes they're
gathering the wood for jobs that have
always been a job of women in all
falador and men are doing this but with
some reluctance and some joking but
they're assuming those tasks that women
have always done before but there are
also women who are fighting as equal
partners alongside the man absolutely
and they're probably right now no more
than 10 or 15 percent women who are
combatants but they're also moving into
other spheres that they haven't before
so a lot of the health workers being
trained they're women a lot of the
communications people being trained or
women and women have opportunities that
they haven't previously had certainly
there is a consciousness-raising going
on all the time with another process of
revolution what sort of threats to these
people in El Salvador who are trying to
build a new society and take democratic
control of their life face from the
government did you see examples of
government incursions into these zones
where they're bombing raids where their
government troops coming in and how did
they relate to these people in these
areas a control zone means an area in
which the guerillas who are the sons and
daughters of the compas inos there have
defended and the soldier death squads
can't enter unless they note a huge
operation in pain so a daily fact of
life the last six or eight months I was
there were air attacks by American
supplied aircraft and there wasn't a day
since July of nineteen
in 82 that there weren't either 837
fighter-bombers attacking Huey
helicopter strafing for observations
planes rocketing the zone and the area
is so small that one aircraft can dip a
wing and strafe here roll back over and
bomb there with absolute impunity the
guerrillas have no Erica any aircraft
capability they don't
whereas in Vietnam they did quite a few
American plan oh they have the most
sophisticated anti-aircraft capability
the world between their missiles in
there and their electronically our radar
control any aircraft guns I think that's
probably one of the biggest evidence as
I saw that they aren't receiving any
significant support from the outside
they fight with fairly primitive weapons
and certainly don't have any any great
supplies of munitions during an invasion
by the government soldiers everyone knew
they had to flee and anyone who was
caught by the government soldiers
usually died and their bodies would
indicate to me they got it fully on
merciful death I had a 76 year old
patient once who was too tired to flee
he had that off right in both knees and
he stayed in hid they found him and
almost twisted his arms off before they
they killed him I am pleased that some
Americans get upset when I talk about
the use of napalm there but I think the
truth of the matter is most of the
people I knew would whether they died
from napalm then be caught by the
government soldiers without Burberry
it was that it was that Barbara they
slaughter babies also I found a 22 day
old baby with a or the bullet hole lines
for him surrounded by powder burns most
interesting for me was learning the
history of the front most of which I did
through patient interviews so in a
prenatal interview I'd ask a pregnant
woman
how many pregnancies have you had a G
might say eight and say how many
children you have living and she would
say one and I would say how many
abortions or miscarriages and she would
say one and I said what happened to the
others
there'd be this out point of anguish and
then she might say well they were burned
in the house at the masker soccer mill
now say what do you mean and she said
well that's when the government soldiers
surrounded a house and burned 36 women
and children and I naively said well why
didn't they run like we do now and she
said well that was before we knew we
were the enemy we had never belonged to
an organization or gone to a
demonstration so the people in this area
were labeled subversives because of what
was happening of what was happening for
the most part was an awakening that i
think there was a large part caused by
the message of vatican ii of medellin
and pueblos of what we call Liberation
Theology that told these very religious
people that their misery was not the
result of God's will but rather the
greed of a few men and they could change
that and so these based Christian
communities inspire people to examine
their own reality and then getting to
address it in nonviolent Christian ways
so they formed associations of
campesinos they form cooperatives they
form unions all of which were a threat
to the existing order and invited
repression first from death squads there
are sons and daughters began ambushing
those death squads that led to the
calling of the government soldiers to
come in in a spiral of violence leading
to the revolution as we know it today
how are you treated in the United States
by the press for instance well there
have been a number of articles about me
and and some people say gee that's
really terrific that we're getting such
press coverage here but the truth of the
matter is it's been rather difficult a
number of the major dailies that that I
attempted to talk to basically said
there's nothing new to talk about on
Salladhor we're not interested in an
interview I've gotten pretty good
coverage when I've gotten in the door
and and been able to talk to some and
then very pleased by that I think that
the media coverage of El Salvador is
very interesting the recent that is the
july/august issue of Nakhla has some
very good examples of what happens
there's a picture in Nicaragua of
children mothers waiting in line with
pails a caption that appeared with that
picture in Business Week was disgruntled
Nicaraguans waiting in long
and for ration food the photographer who
took that picture explained that that
was women and children getting free meat
and milk rations which are given to the
poor in Nicaragua today so we have those
kinds of distortions and about 80
percent of what Americans here it seems
like either comes from the
administration from the State Department
from the embassy those are the sources
that our media usually picks up and
listens to and it's very difficult to
hear the other side of the story when
you're on say talk shows like here in
Austin how did the caller's the people
who call in whether their attitudes well
I was very very surprised here in Austin
that about 80 percent of the calls have
been very supportive to the message that
I carry and that is that that we could
be seeking peaceful solutions in El
Salvador that perhaps we're stopping
change and adding to the violence rather
than understanding the processes
happening there that's not always always
true of course there is a lot of
red-baiting sometimes on talk shows I do
nighttime talk radio shows because the
audience is very different when I give a
public talk like I will here at the
University there may be 300 people
interested in Central America when I do
a talk radio show there may be 5,000 or
10,000 that don't want to hear about
Central America and perhaps need to
learn a little bit more about it from a
different perspective and the sorts of
other distortions have you seen in the
American media of the situation in
Central Americans you've observed that
or as you understand it there's there
been a fairly systematic distortion you
think or just ignoring of things I think
there is a propaganda campaign that's
going on right now which the United
States media has bought into in a sense
in that they certainly swallow basically
whatever the administration the State
Department embassy says without
challenging it and they can get away
with distortions that other people
couldn't probably the biggest part of
that is painting this as a Soviet
east-west confrontation when there has
been very little or any evidence of arms
flow coming into El Salvador
evidence presented so far was the white
paper which was thoroughly discredited
by The Wall Street Journal and yet the
media continues to say the large floor
arms coming from Nicaragua and El
Salvador via via Cuba and to support
that contention which is the basis of
much of our policy in the region finally
today and it's August first for
listeners that will be seeing us later
in the year the New York Times carry an
article in which Reagan administration
officials admitted as well as Salvadoran
military officials admitted that they
could see no evidence of an arm's flow
from Nicaragua to the guerrillas this
year that was my experience there I saw
the weapons they fall when I've spoken
with groups that included ex directors
of the CIA X ambassadors ex members of
the Joint Chiefs of Staff and I've said
perhaps I'm naive but I would like to
see your evidence because I didn't see
it I'm puzzled that the most
sophisticated intelligence service in
the world that has aircraft that fly
over El Salvador daily and take pictures
of a package of cigarettes from 50,000
and read the print can't come up with
any evidence and they say we don't want
to compromise our sources and I say your
sources are these aircraft your sources
are the AWACS plane we just had
stationed down there whose job it was to
detect these aircraft that allegedly
come in El Salvador every night they
couldn't detect any in more than three
months on station and I think that's
basically because there is no great arms
flow I was because of my neutrality and
and because I'm a Quaker was that given
the responsibility of negotiating the
release of prisoners of war from the
guerillas to the International Red Cross
and I had a chance to meet these young
men young men as young as 14 of whom
were drafted or forcibly conscripted
young men who who all admitted that they
thought officers sold munitions to to
the guerrillas or arms to the guerrillas
young men who don't have many choices if
you say why don't you avoid your draft
notice they'll say it endangers our
families if you say why don't you desert
they'll say we've seen the pictures of
deserters whose inscriptions on their
pictures say family killed in a
crossfire and there have been a number
of cases of
out young men who admit to killing women
and children and are taught to do so but
young men who also surrender is one of
the few options to them and after
spending a couple of weeks with the
guerrillas and English Sabah they were
guarded in homes go back profoundly
demoralized because they find the people
are fighting or like themselves they're
poor but they see families they see
worship services they see schools they
see clinics and distribution of food
unlike they've ever seen before so early
on I never saw more than one or two
three prisoners when they start being
turned over to the Red Cross and
therefore guaranteeing their their
survivability because before that the
government would kill them they started
telling their comrades what was
happening they started sweater in 30s
and 40s by December an entire company of
over a hundred surrendered and in 1983
the guerillas have captured over a
thousand prisoners of war and 1,500
weapons they really can't feel many more
troops than the Natha guerillas can't so
they don't need any arms from the
outside but I think the major point the
press has not paid much attention to is
that whether marks Sandino or Castro
were ever born or not there would be a
revolution in Central America and u.s.
foreign policy is only contributing to
the violence and is probably the
greatest obstacle to peace there by
supporting this very brutal and and
corrupt regime what do you think the
real reason is for the American foreign
policy in that area you know and we
would assume they know there's no real
Soviet threat in that area is it just to
try to stem the tide of third
revolutions to overcome the so-called
post-vietnam
syndrome to show that America will not
tolerate any more revolutionary
movements in the third world what are
you thinking about the real reasons for
American foreign policy in that area
well I don't think there's a simple
answer but certainly there's a lot of
shortsightedness on the part of the
Reagan administration I think the
problem is is that we lose if we
associate ourselves with a military
victory or defeat in El Salvador
if we win we have only identified our
cell
with forces of repression and postponed
the next insurrection if we lose we have
only lost the opportunity to bring peace
to Central America through some sort of
negotiated process with a Contador group
and the people who are most concerned
about the Central Americans themselves I
think that probably there's a number of
factors the most important being that we
are preserving the ability of the United
States to operate politically and
economically the way would choose in
Central America and I'm reminded of that
quote by my Marine General Smedley Brown
who said I made Cuba safe for the Brown
Brothers banking in 1914 I made
Nicaragua safe for the National City
Bank boys I made Haiti safe for American
sugar interest in 1916 this kind of
attitude toward Central and South
America that is ours to even lose an
American colony yes it's not ours and
certainly these people should be able to
decide some things for themselves that
was this how does this changed you in
Vietnam you were of the nonviolent
persuasion you know that have you had
any changes within within you to see
where maybe violence can be justified
after being down El Salvador well I
don't think pacifism or a commitment to
non-violence means except naively that
that those are not realities in this
world I think the most serious pacifists
are those that would look to remove the
causes of war of which are corruption
brutality the kind of poverty that we
see in Central America
my understanding of non-violence was
what certainly changed a lot in El
Salvador and I was able to maintain my
commitment to it but I was throwing a
rifle one time when when we were
evacuating about 12 patients and it took
two men each to carry the bamboo poles
that the hammocks were slung from and
one of them threw me a rifle and I had
to ask myself was I going to use that
and and what would it mean to leave my
body beside the road or would I allow
those patients who were wounded to fall
into the hands of the government
soldiers who were often especially
brutal with wounded patients what what
would that serve I didn't have to answer
that question
at another time in a in a bass Christian
community one of the casinos wanted to
know more about what it meant to be a
Quaker they couldn't understand why
didn't carry an arm because certainly
the other physicians did there and I
tried to explain a little bit about
non-violence and and this man a very
reply they stopped me and he said now my
job on the Hacienda he pointed to it it
was just over the way he said had been
to feed the dogs and I had to give them
a large bowl of milk every morning and I
could never afford milk for my children
he said when the dogs were ill I would
have to take him to the veterinarian and
Suchi toto and he said I had never been
able to afford to take my children to
the doctor in SUCI toto and some of them
died for lack of medical care so he said
you Gringo's think of violence in terms
of what's done with a machete or a gun
but there's another kind of violence of
violence to the spirit and until you've
seen your children starve you can't
understand that kind of violence and it
was a very profound lesson I don't think
the people in also door have resorted
the violence as anything but a last
resort and many of them even did that
very reluctantly let me make a plug for
medical aid and I would say this to the
tender listening audience that the
Salvadoran people really make a
distinction between the American people
and the American government and then you
can help in that process because when
they see the daily gifts from the
American government bombs rockets
machine-gun bullets it's a message of
destruction and you can give them a
message of hope in the form of of
medical aid I work with an organization
that distributes medical aid in El
Salvador it's called a Salvadoran
medical relief fund